what's up everyone welcome back to the
channel for yet another conversation
with Ralph Macchio welcome back Ralph
and congratulations on the book waxing
on is uh quite the treat for any fan of
yours but also a fan of The Karate Kid
franchise in general I loved it thank
you thanks thank you it's great to be
back it's a you know just hanging out
with one of my friends who's been on
board since day one it is an honor that
you call me a friend I'll be on board
it's like warm and fuzzy it's like it's
you know you've been there from the the
get-go certainly well I mean the get-go
of the Cobra Kai launch for me but I'm
sure you've been in the Karate Kid
Universe before then for a very very
long time one of the things that I
always look back on is I went to an
event for Hot Tub Time Machine and they
did some sort of like 80s party and I
still have the sweep the leg t-shirt
that I wore at that party and it's it's
black and like completely faded but I'm
never getting rid of that t-shirt well
that's good don't get rid of it because
then you know the show may get canceled
so we don't want that well I was about
to say before I'll be with you guys
until the very end but I I genuinely do
believe there is there is no end and I
feel like some of the stuff that you
touch on in the book basically I don't
know confirms the longevity of the
franchise and the fact that these themes
are going to continue on and on and
really strike a chord with every
generation moving forward I think so
listen the execution has to be well told
and you need great writers and and like
we have a John Josh and Hayden and
certainly with Robert Mark Cayman who
created The Karate Kid uh uh characters
in the original script it there's you
know it has become a little bit the
Marvel Cinema The Karate Kid Cinematic
Universe
um um there are other ideas other
spin-off ideas
um more length to the Cobra Kai series
although we don't have an official
season six pickup yet that's the
question of I'm getting it every
interview I don't uh we don't have that
yet but we feel
confident thanks to all you folks that
um that want to watch it uh that we'll
have more more life and and what was
born in the you know in the fall of 1983
when we were making this movie The
Karate Kid who knew I mean I was gonna
save that question for after the book
talk but I guess I'll just throw it out
there right now so so you are all just
actually sitting there awaiting the
Netflix pickup and like you're not
you're not at the point where you're
thinking that a season six shooting
start date is a is a locked guarantee
there's no listen there's no lock
guarantees in anything correct so in
life but uh
um there's a high confidence and
discussions but there's not the you know
we don't have that official official
word so but I'm feeling good and I'm
feeling the book is not going to hurt
our chances either I think it's just
nice to have
you know me speak of the Journey of
almost 40 years in the shoes of of
Daniel Larusso and and what it's been
like for me personally and and how it it
is represents Nostalgia and contemporary
relevance at the same time uh that's
just um you know very unique to have a
story that's ongoing and a character
that so has been so impactful and
inspirational and aspirational wish
fulfilling for so many uh people and so
many generations now so
here's my segue maybe not a locked
guarantee but it would absolutely Boggle
my brain could not compute any scenario
where we don't get the official word in
the very near future I hope so I think
you're probably right but we'll see
speaking it into existence right now
um so your for your book uh why why now
is there anything in particular that
maybe you experienced while filming
seasons four and five of Cobra Kai that
made you think now is the right time in
Karate Kid fandom to share my story
well certainly there's such a heightened
relative you know um
relative it's so relative right now and
it's oh but the pandemic did have a hand
in it I mean I started writing it maybe
a month six weeks after lockdown when we
still every day it was about what's the
numbers and what's happening and and
this was also when season three of Cobra
Kai was in the can and YouTube was no
longer going to continue and we had not
landed at Netflix yet
um but we did have those 10 episodes in
our back pocket so once again just like
the season I felt confident we would
have landed someplace else obviously the
Netflix was the global explosion of it
all
um so so as far as having the time to
focus on writing the book proposal which
is what came first you know laying down
the chapters the chapter titles coming
up with clever titles that I thought
would would um would you know draw
someone into what is the promise of that
and and whether it's Strawberry
Shortcake in the cannoli which is
Elizabeth's shoe and Daniel Larusso in a
way we can uh director John Adelson
would call us or the crane takes flight
which is the summer of 84 and then I
just started writing little paragraphs
of what the promise of those chapters
could be and then we had a great deal of
interest from many Publishers and it was
just that timing had a lot to do with it
but but on top of that what's unique
what is unique is we have an entity a
motion picture a movie that's become a
big part of pop culture for decades and
now a a show on on uh it was YouTube at
the time but a show that was that was
blowing up when showing that these you
can come into this universe from
different angles and then dive into the
gray areas of these characters that were
so black and white when they were
initiating and originally set up
and then have a younger generation back
themselves into this whole franchise
being able to write to that and pepper
that throughout even though it was
really a for the most part it's a
chronological walk in my shoes but I'd
always I'd be able to jump back and
forth say with a scene from The Karate
Kid or something that that happened to
me while filming or some relationship
and then how that pays forward and is
from a different perspective in the
Cobra Kai series or what I've gained out
of the lessons on both in my own life
and now I'm saying this is a book this
is a unique book unique mainly because
only I could tell this story of him
having walked in those shoes and unique
and there are not many examples
of a movie that has stood the test of
time and has become part of you know a
big part of pop culture and now is a
potential number one Netflix show
so it you know all of the above long
answer but that is those all the
components that went into it all right I
want to hit some of these components now
before I get into specifics is there any
particular memory from working on the
franchise that change the more you dug
into it while writing the book like
something about the journey that
revealed itself to be more important to
you than you had ever realized before
when you were writing about it yeah
that's a great question and yes that
happened probably a few times
um it was really interesting going to
mainly season four is where I wrote The
Lion's Share
of the book room in Atlanta and was
shooting it's winter it's freezing we're
pretending we're in California it's just
crazy but somehow we do it with this
show Cobra California is what I call it
um and uh I'm shooting during the day
we're on lockdown for the most part when
we're not in front of the cameras
there's barely any restaurants open you
have to just do take out so I had no
excuse
um and I'd sit there and I'd be you know
diving into areas of certain chapters
and you know sort of telling the story
say uh since I alluded to a strawberry
shortcake in the cannoli the Elizabeth's
shoe Journey what that was like for me
um looking at what it must have been
like for her to be written out of the
original film in one line of dialogue in
the in the Karate Kid Part Two never I
was always so wrapped up at that point
um in my life I was I was heading out to
do a movie called teachers right after
Karate Kid I had Crossroads uh in in
development that I was going to shoot I
was then following up with the De Niro
play on Broadway so I was you know my
mindset was I was wrapped up into my own
thing and as I was writing that that
chapter because we got to deal with that
narratively in season three of Cobra Kai
what happened to Ali with an i and what
was the the truth and it was emotional
to shoot that stuff in the three of us
together which made all you fans very
very happy
um and she was so so great uh coming
back to do that and
so there's an example of me for the
first time saying you know what I Ralph
today would have picked up the phone uh
Ralph today probably would have had a um
maybe an understanding of what she went
through instead of you know just being
so I don't want I would not call myself
self-absorbed I was busy I was busy and
I was young you know so so that's one
small example
um others are you know and talking about
my relationship with Pat Morita and this
sort of Soulful magic of what I call
that partnership that without that
partnership there is no Cobra Kai
because there is no Karate Kid without
Mr Miyagi honestly
um we could have as many body bags and
legs swept as we want but if you didn't
have that heart and soul in that movie
that movie doesn't work all right so
diving into some of those areas and and
having those moments on set with Cobra
Kai after writing about Pat and I and
John avilson and making some of those
iconic scenes from the film and then
stepping on the Cobra Kai set and seeing
the town of buchananas Robbie or the
show alone as uh as Miguel
um and looking at those you know Miguel
is essentially the millennial Daniel
Larusso kind of at least in The Upfront
of overkai and in playing those scenes
with them from the perspective of the
Sensei or teacher life has moved on I'm
now not the 17 year old kid or even the
make-believe 16 year old kid I was
um that that was emotional
you know to to write about where it all
began and and how it's still living and
breathing you know and without John
Appleton and Pat Morita so it was
emotional
kind of going back to the alley stuff
and building on that a little because
those are the types of things that you
you talk about in the book quite
extensively and in particular when it
came to Karate Kid 3 the opportunity to
use Cobra Kai to strengthen things that
maybe should have been stronger or
handled differently in the film
franchise is there anything left in that
department that whether it's in season
six or something down the line maybe in
a spin-off series that you think there's
great opportunity to go back and
strengthen even more yeah I think um
listen credit John Josh and Hayden they
have take a um I mean Karate Kid three
listen Karate Kid 3 informed a lot of
how they write because you know Cobra
Kai has that bigger than life sometimes
even cartoon element to the superhero
element to it yet then you have these
father-son moments and these these uh
family moments that have such great
Hearts it's almost it's really
interesting because there are times this
show is like three different shows and
but they also it all sustains because
the themes are still the same it's
bullying mentorship fatherless teens uh
single parenting Fish Out of Water
overcoming obstacles it's all those
themes from The Karate Kid are all true
to COBRA Kai so yeah and looking at what
has what they've done with the chosen
taguchi character in The Great Yuji
okamoto who's like the MVP of season
five or one of for sure
um you know these are great actors that
just you you give them the the material
to work with and then they knock it out
of the park and Thomas Ian Griffiths I
mean he got to and I write this in the
book and this was like a last minute
both you know when we were locking the
manuscript but yet still shooting season
five I was like wait I can't put this
out yet these guys every day I'm getting
something new from them and I added just
a sentence or two because I couldn't do
much more than that
um you know to to talk about the long
Jeffrey how it continues to live on and
grow and add more layers to these
characters that might have been a little
more two-dimensional or it would
definitely more two-dimensional back in
those sequels
um so yeah I think there's there's room
and I'm never see I'm in there never
seems to be amazed with what our three
our big three come up with in their
whole writing staff and and the nuances
that they add and layers and it's really
quite special I always trust them with
that stuff they work some uh some magic
that I never expected to get
um I wanted to ask you this one because
I I asked it to someone else recently
and got the most beautiful answer and
revisiting your journey in the franchise
has me thinking about it so you
obviously found great great success
early on as a young actor in this
industry but is there anything that
you've seen any of the young stars of
Cobra Kai do that you wish you could
kind of you know put in your pocket and
take back to your younger self and say
like try this do this too
oh to myself right yeah I'd like to be
as good as all of them at the martial
arts
I would like to just be Tanner and Jacob
fruit just for one afternoon
um and Mary Mauser how about Mary's the
work she's from season one never
throwing a kick in her life to to how
much work she's put in to Samantha's uh
martial arts so yeah there I mean I was
dedicated I certainly certainly was and
um you know at least I have one crane
kick in my back pocket that'll that'll
always be heard around the world right
um but uh yeah I mean
they're uh and and some of the ability
to Pat Morita had this as well and and
and uh Jacob is great at this it's the
ability to come in and out of it in a
snap of a finger he'll just be cracking
jokes prankstering and then cry like and
then back and Pat Marie would do that
too he'd do the great Miyagi drunk scene
tears in his eyes of losing his wife and
child in the in the internment camps and
then we'd cut then you know he you know
have a few fart jokes for me and make me
laugh and take me 10 minutes to get back
into care so I I Marvel with people that
are able to do that those are just some
riffing on some things
all right I gotta let you go soon I
could talk to you forever about this
franchise I think you all know that at
this point I'll go for one last little
season six T's here through something
you mentioned in the book so you had
brought up that you always tell John
Josh and Hayden something that's
important for you in terms of where they
could take Daniel's Ark in any
particular season so I know you probably
don't want to reveal anything for what's
to come but is there anything you could
at least tease about how that's kind of
shifted or evolved with what you
suggested to them for season six and
Beyond
well we haven't had that sit down yet
that we do every season to talk about
where we're gonna go but I I will say
this much it's taken longer than
um I initially expected to get to the
Daniel Larusso say of season five where
it was you know early on in the show and
Daniel
at times was set up just to be the thorn
for Johnny
and now that's all kind of evened out
through all the characters you know
because but the it's you needed the time
to be able to do that you needed it to
breathe but
um I certainly you know one of my
favorite things of season five is that
is seeing Larusso get to a place where
we hadn't seen him before where he's
losing grip on everything even though
he's the only one who knows the truth
and to see
um
his family and friends and foes all come
together and have his back at that point
he very much felt like the the young the
Aging but young protagonist that he that
we all that when when we met him he was
truly you know in that moment when
everyone comes together to say we we
have your back and we're going to do
this moving forward I I like and I like
skinning my knees I like not shaving for
a couple of days that was kind of fun
you know I I love being in my suits at
the dealership but I like seeing you
know peeling the layers off and more and
more and and um you know larusso's
intentions are always good for the most
part he might have slipped a few times
because it's still a soap opera and we
need to show that but um
um but I'd always fight for that I would
say no matter if even if he's being like
a jerk and a dick or whatever here and
there this is a character that we have
to honor is is always wanting to do do
good which is what he's been from his
initial Incarnation and we we're there
with that so I didn't answer your
question but there's great stuff to come
folks I promise you you're all too good
at like teasing things and giving like
legit nothing away how many times have
we done this and I still haven't learned
my lesson I know it's good but you're
it's it's good it's still it's great and
I and there's a PL there's plenty of
that stuff in the book too I really
write to all of that and where that and
where it sits in the world for me and uh
and the way the fans sit because the
truth is if you know you get to the end
of this book that's what that's what
really they've kept this alive they
won't they've never allowed it to go
away and so it's a tribute to them as I
have to let you go I'll emphasize that
it re it really is something else and to
everybody out there waxing on it's
essential if you're a fan of Ralphs and
of course you are if you're a fan of
Cobra Kai Karate Kid you name it do get
it I listen to it I'm so happy that you
narrated it all so I feel like that
created an extra like level of uh of the
experience there so highly recommend it
in either form congratulations Ralph
thank you very great to talk to you